hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and we have a new
official trailer for the defenders a
team of series with daredevil Jessica
Jones Luke Cage and iron fist and it's
got everything we love about Netflix
Marvel shows a hallway fight apparently
for ground level superheroes in New York
their hallways are a freaking deathtrap
anyway I'm going to break down
everything you might have missed in this
trailer along with the prediction er -
about what we might see when the season
comes out on August 18th so let's get
started
you have interrupted a citywide
investigation you saw evidence from my
crime scene and you got my one lead
killed I was trying to help him but you
didn't Jesse Jones stop talking how the
hell are you My name is Matthew Murdock
I mean returning okay so this trailer
opens with the character crossover we've
been waiting for with Matthew Murdock
taking on Jessica Jones as a client Matt
just a suggestion I know a couple other
superheroes who might need a good lawyer
Steve Rogers and his buddy
anyway I'm curious to know exactly what
case misty Knight is working on here
that Jessica Jones has interfered with
and which suspect she ends up getting
accidentally killed I'm guessing that
his blood on her face here also I
appreciate how as usual Jessica Jones
still has her own unique way of opening
locked doors
now obviously the music throughout this
trailer is Nirvana's come-as-you-are
it's actually the same song used in that
super short defenders teaser that came
out during Comic Con last summer and I
had a few theories for how these lyrics
might be fanatically connected to the
story which I went into in my breakdown
of that teaser so go check it out but
one detail that I liked in this scene is
the use of colour now in their solo
series Jessica Jones and daredevil do a
lot of cool stuff with color grading
like Jessica Jones often used the color
purple to associate Jones's past trauma
from kilgrave who's the purple man in
the comics and for sure red is
Daredevils colour it's the deep blood
crimson of his costume reflecting his
anger and the blood that he gives in
defence of Health kitchen and take us
out this is cool these colors play into
this scene as well
purple tinted light in the intere
nation room with Matt barging in through
this bright red door
cool let's move on
how this being harlem's hero allow you
to live an actual life right now that's
what I'll people
I think there's somebody you need to me
hey what are you doing today who you who
you how come she can't be hurt what's
the deal with that fist
I'm the immortal I'm just you well
you're on the same side okay so while it
seems like Matt and Jessica will meet
through their legal connections the
other half of the defenders will
assemble on the streets of Harlem and
yeah this makes sense because Luke Cage
and iron fist have historically been
partners they were part of the Heroes
for Hire comic series we also see Luke
passing the barbershop where he locked
his mentor pop and remember got
destroyed at the end of that season with
his fight with Diamondbacks and this
hinted that it's like this place don't
want to be a Bubba show people and I'm
thinking that maybe the reason we're
seeing it here might be that this place
will be indeed repurposed
perhaps as the headquarters for the
defenders and then quickly after Luke
chapter bed with Claire temple movie
some interesting visuals that kind of
look like different lenses swapping over
the frames now this is kind of similar
imagery to what we saw in Jessica Jones
remember which followed Jessica actually
used a telephoto lens to spy on people
as a PI so it looks like that
voyeuristic aesthetic will come back
into this show as well we also see Danny
Rand and Colleen wing as they walk
through this door and it makes it be a
coincidence but look at back in the
store it's covered with these ceiling
and torn posters it kind of looks like
the visuals in that defenders freezer
last summer it'll be cool to see is that
kind of how these four become aware of
each other like seeing these grimy
markings that people have left about
them around town and these shots of a
fistfight between Luke and Danny are
just great like I love how Luke just
puts them down of her followed by Danny
powering up assist calling back that
things
slow-motion punch shot from Luke Cage
for this time Danny is actually able to
kind of leave a mark and yeah this all
kind of feels like the Avengers like
when Iron Man and Thor had their
infighting in the woods and yeah maybe
like those guys a good brawl it's really
the only way these two heroes on the
same side will earn each other's respect
all right let's move on
you for the devil of Hell's Kitchen the
smartass detectives we got a problem
the righteous X goin down we're on the
kid with a glowing fish the war for New
York is here
so in this section we hear the voice of
stick run down each of the four main
characters and the threat they're facing
as we see all these people in their
natural element like Jessica Jones loads
up on whiskey and smashes the glass in a
closed bar Matt perches on a health
kitchen rooftop listening to distant
sirens and Luke again hooks caught in a
bad situation
notice that bent up metal gate behind
him I feel like he was just thrown into
that seconds earlier so interesting to
see Luke's back in this Seagate prison
jumpsuit remember that was the Georgia
Island prison that he broke out of years
earlier and since the ended last season
in police custody maybe that's where
they're taking him back to but yeah
given how easily he snaps these cuffs I
doubt it'll be a little for very long
and real quick in this trick shot of
Danny fighting there appears to be a
woman in this fight I'm not sure if
that's Colleen or Electra whom we see in
the next shot as the lid of the stone
resurrection chambers lifted officers
remember we saw the hand place
electrodes body in there at the end of
daredevil season two and now it seems
like she's being resurrected to fight on
their side so I think there's a good
chance of will see Elektra as a villain
in this season of the defenders working
on behalf of the hand then after we see
the parked cars get hit with a shock
wave check out this fight in this
abandoned theater looking space if you
look closely it seems like thick it's
presiding over this making it seem like
this could be part of their training
maybe as a group but then if you look
even more closely there's some weird
stuff going on in the shot it is being
knocked back by someone who looks like
they have two glowing fit now it's
impossible to make out who this is but
if you watch the season of iron fist
you may remember bakudo showing Danny's
footage of an old iron fist from 1948 to
MEC I fought with two glowing hands and
we never found out who exactly that was
but he may be connected whoever this is
and the Saints in and other quick shots
of this shockwave scene it looks like
Luke is positioned where that person
would've been so maybe like Luke and
Danny collided in the air and blew each
other back along with the rest of the
room and some of Danny's glowing fists
left some residue on Luke I don't
really no but then there's this other
figure in booths lying on the ground and
I don't see a head or is that hairy
looking clump on the right this guy's
head sick what did you do now there's
obviously a lot happening here very much
an active crime scene in fact maybe this
was a literal crime scene that sick and
the defenders were going to investigate
and they found this headless corpse may
be a victim of the hands or a lecturer
or something else leading to some kind
of argument or infighting between them
anyway I'm guessing we'll learn more
about this as time goes on but let's
move on so get your [ __ ] together more
connections you have it easier it will
be to break
okay so in this section we see sigourney
weaver's Mysterious Villain Alexandra
and I like how the music syncs up with a
shot with Kurt Cobain's voice singing
hey old enemy dolis new Ripley live in a
gerbil now we still don't know much
about Alexandra some are saying that she
might be a female version of Alexander
but now in the daredevil comics bond was
an old-school predecessor to kingpin
before Wilson Fisk but he's not that
much of a major player so I don't think
the shows going in that direction but
maybe the name is still a reference to
him but notice how emmalin seems to feel
physically threatened by Alexandra like
matt has his fists up so I'm thinking
that she might also have a more mystical
power raps related to black sky it's
also possible that she's a human
incarnation of the beef remember the
Beast is the demonic entity worshiped by
the hand and they're trying to summon it
into this realm and yeah it probably
related to that big hole that the hand
ascends digging I'm also not sure what
to make of Alexandra's line here more
connections you have here will be freaky
like on one level she could be
suggesting that the complicated
connections and infighting among the
four of them will make the defenders
easier to break up but yeah she could
also be talking about the other
connections that each of these
characters have to their personal lives
Claire Colleen misty Karen Trish Gerry
Senor foggy guys how's interesting to
you Senor foggy to break up the
defenders
I feel like three of them wouldn't
really care anyway moving on
or scarf
awesome so here we get some more action
in this great exchange between Matt and
Jessica with him wearing her scarf for
school and I like how matt is kind of
reverting to his season one DIY style of
base coverage basically this whole raid
seemed like a rushed last-minute charge
on Alexandra and her forces like this
corporate hallways that has a similar
white wall to where we saw Alexandra in
the earlier shot so I feel like this
whole sequence might be part of an early
or mid season confrontation when they're
still getting a sense of how dangerous
Alexandra is also yeah apparently a
lecture will be part of its battle too
like she slammed Matt through a glass
window and he appears menacingly
approaching behind them in hallway so
yeah once again it seems like a lecture
is going to be fighting for the forces
of evil for at least part of this season
like she might be like kind of a
bodyguard for Alexandra that stops the
defenders from getting all the way to
her here but really yeah I'm just super
pumped to see the defenders bring back
this hallway by staple and it's cool to
see each of the four of them fight in
their own way like Luke smashes through
drywall and then Danny like jumps off
the wall here and Jessica just sensibly
stays the hell out of the way even
though yeah she's a total bat like this
is such a great Avengers style team-up
moment and I love it like maybe Luke
will pick up and throw a lionfish just
consider it and let's look at this final
section no are you talking about bullets
blind ninja whatever it is you are
classy great so a lot of people are
saying that this Chinese food dinner is
similar to that Avengers war machine
maybe I see the parallels but it sounds
like these guys aren't really a team yet
in this seems like they haven't really
been tested they're still figuring out
whether they even want to be a team and
I like Jessica's joke here like Danny
doesn't need to know whatever powers are
exactly just that she's a classy lady
also it makes sense that Danny would be
the one who's most eager for all of them
to come together while Jessica would be
the most ethical right like jessica has
always been the biggest loner of the
bunch while Danny seems to be more
idealistic than the others I'm just
really excited to see how all of these
characters dynamics play off each other
and how they manage to come together and
take down the hand and the mysterious
threat of Alexandra okay that covers
this trailer for the defenders I'm just
super excited for the show like overall
I've really enjoyed what Netflix has
done with all these Marvel heroes and I
think we're all due for some payoff of
seeing them bicker and collaborate and
yet hopefully Frank castle will show up
at some point now if you liked this
video please hit like and subscribe to
new rockstars share this with your
friends you can also contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons you guys are all awesome
especially you Kelly hopper you can hit
me up on Twitter a TA boss with any
thoughts the predictions you have about
the defenders or follow new rockstars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
our videos ok thanks for watching bye
[Music]